I'm gonna be reviewing the dopest
tik-tok food hats in the game right now
I'm Gianna G I'm a chef and I also have
a cooking channel called cooking whiskey
and no I'm not zendaya they're gonna be
four hi first hi
DIY Egg McMuffin he's building an Egg
McMuffin at home
so he's putting the egg in a mug he's
cooking the mug with the egg and
steaming and he's taking the hand
cutting it out with the cup and you
build it put them together and then this
amazing egg mcmuffin sandwich we're
gonna start by taking our cup and trying
to make the perfect slice that fits the
perfect muffin my muffin somewhere on
here the egg whites are seeping out the
sides
I still have faith you can see the egg
just stuck to the mother and it's better
I guess
I think that's pretty legit I didn't let
her really inside the mug so make it
after typically user I also I noticed my
egg didn't steam I don't know if it's
because I didn't pull the mug down or
maybe they're doing some secret tricks
and they didn't show us oh damn the yolk
first and everywhere that's a great
accent stop this hack must try delicious
Egg McMuffin sandwich I'm gonna go wash
my hands now
the next pack we are going to make an
avocado flower she just cut the avocado
in half so I knew that she starts
slicing it and then she starts rolling
it in like it looks easy looks pretty
easy I think I got this I just took over
Gatos place it right in half
I don't know why she's massage of akkad
oh maybe it was to get the avocado in
the mood something like this dang it why
is so hard I am going to try this again
this moving the small and inward around
I'm definitely not the pro yet but I
definitely think it depends on the
ripeness of the avocado so that you have
enough wiggle room to move avocados
around the neck pack let's get the skins
of these back boys
nice and quick she's just pretty much
sauteing the tomatoes westside down a
little bit of oil covering them so they
see she's petting a cat come back to it
the peel comes off nice and easy so
we're gonna build some Tomatoes y'all so
I'm gonna begin by slicing my tomatoes
in half get the oil hot flesh side down
out of lid you can take about five
minutes so it's been about five minutes
I love this tomato food it's almost like
reconquer saying it but not really
because you never shot the tomatoes
afterwards which is really interesting
because I feel like if you want to have
you know warm Tomatoes without the peel
this is the way to do the next time
rainbow ramen in the video she's just
boiling by three packs of noodles
she's dividing the noodles in different
bowls and then adding different food
colorings to make rainbow spectrum of
colors I've got water boiling I'm gonna
pop - they're Google's and noodle babies
where you I know you know it's one of
those things I have three different
flavors of ramen because might as well
taste the rainbow and see the rainbow at
the same time really exciting I like
doing this because it reminds me of when
I was a child
we're gonna mix everything yeah cuz
they're like they're like pastel I'm
like rainbow noodles I think it's fun
especially like you have like an
activity that you want to do so I did
notice if you want it to be vibrant and
popping just like these you're gonna
have to add a lot of food coloring so I
mean that's when you have to compromise
do you want to be eating all this to die
for the clout or not I love trying to
stick soft food hacks I learned so much
from them I hope you guys enjoy them
no down below you're enough anymore to
contacts that you want to do strike
[Music]